hi there steve kaufman here
uh i always talk about language learning
uh i would like to talk about other
subjects too
uh including politics i'm here in the
states you know i could talk about uh
the primaries and uh donald trump and
bernie sanders and
talk about our new uh prime minister in
canada whom uh well i won't go there
um
one of the things that comes out in all
of this is that there is a great deal of
dissatisfaction obviously with with
conventional politicians but also
there's a lot of uneasiness uh because
so many people who used to be in the
middle class no longer feel that they're
in the middle class uh it used to be
that if you had a good job in the local
factory
um and perhaps your wife had a job in
the factory maybe your kids had a job in
the factory i mean you were wealthy
and you didn't necessarily have a very
high level of education and many of
those jobs no longer exist and they're
not likely to come back
so
um
what can a person do well that's where i
believe that reading
and listening the same things that are
so powerful for language learning are
extremely important in order for people
to be competitive
in the new economy of course there's no
guarantee that every educated person
will get a job or a good job however
there are all kinds of statistics that
show that the degree of of literacy of a
person
in other words how well they read how
many words they know all the things that
are important in learning languages
these are also the things that will
determine how well you do in society how
well you do at school how well you do in
your job even technical jobs
the level of literacy required to read
manuals instructional manuals is very
very high so yes there are problems with
people who have reading disabilities
and and i think that these people who
have reading disabilities they have to
help themselves as much as possible
other people may help them but
we know for example that that
listening and reading are very closely
connected people who don't read well
also have trouble discerning sounds to
some extent and so these are things that
we have to work on so in other words
if we spend the time again just as in
language learning if you have an
attitude that says i am going to improve
my reading and listening skills i'm
going to improve my vocabulary
if you have that kind of attitude and
you're convinced that you're going to
succeed
and you put the time into it so you
won't be watching the football game on
tv or you won't be a going to the bar to
drink beer or you won't be whatever else
it is that you do that might be
wonderful
it might even mean taking time away from
your family but you're going to devote
that to improving your reading and
listening skills this
in itself
i think will have a major impact on
you know flattening out that that
widening disparity between the wealthy
which is largely those that have a high
rate of literacy and the poor who by and
large don't now there's always
exceptions there's very well educated
people who have poor jobs there's
uneducated people who have good jobs
i've worked with people who have serious
reading disabilities and who are
excellent at what they do in very
demanding managerial positions
there are athletes and singers there's
all kinds of exceptions
however by and large statistically the
better you read and listen the better
your vocabulary the broader your
knowledge
the better you do
and in order to to um
become better as a reader and a listener
you have to work at it much the same way
as we work at our language learning
skills so
related to language learning on the
edges of politics
uh there it is read and listen
were you listening
anyway bye for now